well fire crews in California say
they've concerned that wind and drought
conditions will keep fueling wildfires
already burning in the state crews
launched an aggressive attack on the so
called County fire yesterday it's
currently the largest wildfire in
California and one of at least 60 fires
burning in the country most of them are
in the West John Blackstone is in Yolo
County near Sacramento John good morning
good morning well firefighters from
across California have come to battle
this fire now in its sixth day it's
about 27 percent contained but there are
fears that high winds and shifting winds
and triple digit temperatures this
weekend could make things worse fire
crews in rural Northern California are
tackling steep and rugged terrain to
battle the County fire the inferno that
began on Saturday has now burned through
more than 86,000 acres Daniel Sanchez is
with cAL FIRE which is directing nearly
3,000 firefighters working to control
the flames threatening more than a
thousand homes and buildings and
continues further is gonna be hard and
harder to get there's no roads out there
really so bulldozers are cutting their
way in try to get our troops in there to
finish it off thick smoke made flying
especially challenging for helicopters
assisting fire fighters from overhead
in basalt Colorado near Aspen
helicopters and air tankers shuttled
water and retardant over the lake
Christine fire after shifting winds
caused flames to explode above the trees
hundreds of homes threatened by the fire
have been forced to evacuate MIT shut ik
ben joni Haggerty left Wednesday
afternoon wind had started blowing up
towards our house it's so dry we knew
that if anything caught it would start
to go right away police ticketed two
people for allegedly starting the fire
at a nearby shooting range extreme
conditions plaguing the southwest are
fueling half a dozen fires across
Colorado alone the Spring Creek fire
southwest of Denver has already burned
through an area about half the size of
New York City making it the third
largest fire in Colorado history as soon
as we saw four planes fly directly over
our head we realized we need to get out
of here firefighters in Colorado are
hoping that rain today will help them
get a much-needed break from these fires
across the country wildfires have burned
through two and a half million acres
since January that's well above the
average for this time of year
Alix John banks at a dramatic footage